sergey lavrov is wrapping up a five-day
visit to the african continent
the russian foreign minister's trip came
as moscow tries to find new allies amid
growing isolation from the west
i think that sergey lavrov wants to show
that russia's post-western foreign
policy is really taking off and he views
the russia and african partnership as
some kind of alliance against the
american and european efforts to
preserve a unipolar order russia has
been condemned by
europe and a lot of countries
and there is a need for russia to
continue to present itself to a domestic
audience as legitimate that it still has
friends in the world
back in march only about half of the 54
african countries supported the un
resolution calling for russian troops to
withdraw from ukraine
there's a large number who feel like
number one that punishing russia with
sanctions is actually exacerbating the
problem and that neutrality is the path
to supporting a diplomatic solution
number two this is not necessarily our
fight like european countries western
countries so most african countries are
looking at at all means using all means
possible to balance the relationships
that they have so what we have here is
not so much that russia has been
successful in convincing africans about
this or that europe has not been
successful it's just that african
countries weighing their interests are
taking a rational decision based on that
and in this case that decision means
we're not going to antagonize the
russians we're not going to condemn the
russians and mars
lavrov's trip began in egypt the country
that did vote in favor of the un
resolution but has nevertheless
maintained close business ties with
russia
just days ago russia's state-owned
atomic energy giant rosatom began
constructing egypt's first nuclear power
plant
specifically in egypt russia is looking
for closer relations
with uh the arab league via egypt and
also to he make sure the aldebaran
nuclear reactor and the source canal
industrial zone projects remain uh
spinning grain exports were also high up
on lavrov's agenda in egypt the country
imported 80 percent of its wheat from
russia and ukraine last year
lavrov offered reassurances over russian
deliveries amid uncertainty over a deal
to resume ukrainian exports from the
black sea
[Music]
while visiting the republic of congo
uganda and ethiopia lavrov's focus
shifted onto a different russian export
weapons
i think outside of egypt
especially the countries south of the
sahara
their staples uh are not really
you know
based on wheat they have other things
that they that they eat maize salgum
cassava but i think a lot of african
countries depend on russia and china for
their weapons and weapons systems and so
that is an issue and they will not want
to burn those bridges i think that
russia has been incrementally trying to
expand its influence in africa they have
been a reliable purveyor of arms to
african countries the leading uh seller
ahead of china france and the united
states over the last five years 44
percent of major arms imports to africa
came from russia
[Music]
with ethiopia the final lag of lavrov's
visit to the continent being among the
largest importers south of the sahara
the country has been accused of human
rights violations in its war against
rebels in the tigray region
but russia has shielded ethiopia at the
un security council by objecting to
statements condemning abuses by the
country's armed forces
meanwhile western countries have
suspended aid to ethiopia of the war on
tigray
the same could happen to other african
countries despite efforts by many of
them to not pick a side on ukraine some
eu diplomats have reportedly argued in
favor of cutting aid to countries
maintaining close ties with russia that
would make it a lot harder to balance
relationships
they're doing everything they can not to
be caught in like a cold war situation
where they're forced to make a choice
however
from the documents that we've seen from
eu
it looks like the eu is going to begin
to condition its assistance to african
countries based on the kinds of choices
they make african countries will slowly
get into a place where it's like a cold
war 2.0
you